a rescue operation going on a lot more
boats here today compared to yesterday
they're going in and picking out mainly
elderly or vulnerable people we've seen
a couple of people in wheelchairs who've
been brought out because the waters have
risen quite dramatically overnight we
could walk down this street yesterday
now you can't get down this unless you
you're in a boat and people have woken
up this morning and found that the
waters they live on the second or the
third floor and they're finding the
waters have risen up that high so
there's a bit of a pace going on now to
try and reach them as quickly as
possible and bring them all out
foreign